according to new polls Millennials
prefer Democrats over Republicans in
this year's midterm elections 60% at 59%
actually of Millennials say they would
prefer to see Democrats running Congress
than Republicans they also have a higher
favorability rating of Democrats over
Republicans by a pretty large margin
almost 20 points and that's the only the
good news though in fact that's the only
good news because also according to the
same poll only 55 percent of Millennials
say that they are either definitely or
probably going to vote in this year's
midterm elections and this is what I
want to end with today these last few
minutes here it's talking about
Millennials and voters first and
foremost this has very little if
anything to do with the fact that they
prefer Democrats over Republicans good
for you guys I'm with you on that but
that's not what this is about only 55
percent of you say you plan on voting
that's not okay that's not acceptable
and it's not just about oh the current
makeup of the government this is about
your future Millennials of which I
happen to be in that age group granted I
am at the very tip-top of it but I'm
still in it
we're the largest voting bloc in the
United States now that's how big we are
that's how much power we have as a
voting group but if we sit at home if we
sit on the sidelines if we don't get
active and get involved then that power
is meaningless
it doesn't actually exist the power only
is there when you choose to exercise it
so that is the message that I am sending
to millennial voters all over the United
States right now it doesn't matter who
you vote for it doesn't matter if you
want to be a strict party loyalist or if
you want to be a free-thinking person
who says I like this party on this idea
and this one on this idea
get out there and exercise that power
because if you don't we've already seen
states try to pass laws that say if you
didn't vote in the last election you
can't vote in the next one which means
you can't vote in the next one or the
next one they will try to take it away
because they understand how powerful it
is and for the record it's Republicans
who are trying to take that away so
factor that and when you choose who to
vote for but nonetheless educate
yourselves pay attention to the
candidates learn who they are what they
stand for and determine for yourself
which one has your best interests at
heart
because when we talk about Millennials
we have to understand that of all the
generations that are here today except
for the one behind the Millennials
they're going to be directly affected by
every single thing that happens that
these older generations might not have
to deal with as much things like rising
sea level dude climate change there are
voters already alive today who by the
time they reach their sixties or
seventies
some cities in the United States because
of rising sea level are not going to
exist we already have an island down
here in the state of Louisiana that is
disappearing and about 10 years it will
be gone it is a city and it's going to
be gone it won't exist anymore now
that's gonna happen all over this
country in coastal coastal areas we see
it we see it happening now they have to
deal with it they have to fix that
student loan debt crisis Medicare for
all the list is endless of things that
these young American voters know that
they want fixed but they just don't know
who's going to fix it for them but if
you don't get out there educate yourself
about the candidates then these things
will not get fixed the older generation
doesn't care about these things that's
pretty obvious at this point some of
them do don't get me wrong a lot of them
do but not enough of them and so I leave
with the message to the Democratic and
Republican parties don't just assume
that you've got these kids votes in your
pocket
you have to go out there and earn them
because if you don't you can't get mad
at them for staying home
you have to offer them a better future a
better path forward and a better America
that's on the party's not on the voters
I want to thank David Pakman max Patrick
Noah everybody for letting me fill in
this week this has been truly a ton of
fun I love doing it if you want any more
from me I'm also filling in for Sam
cedar and ring a fire this coming
weekend so tune in Saturdays and Sundays
you can find me on Twitter at fair and
balanced YouTube
at youtube.com slash the Ring of Fire
thank you again everyone it's been a
remarkable week I'll see you on today's
bonus show have a good one